And now it's the old scout master.
So there was this tenderfoot scout who had no class.
No really. I mean he was trying to send a secret message using the outdoor code.
That doesn't work. I mean, he got all his dots and dashes mixed up and he had to send it a second time.
He was very remorseful.
Hey, this is podcast number 70..
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green.
Uh-oh,
That's the big drums.
Oh, and the fanfare.
Well, well, well,
That means, of course,
we've happened upon an auspicious occasion, because this is podcast number 70..
Number 70.
Okay, well, I appreciate. uh, let me give myself a little pat on the back there.
We've hit number 70.
So I started the scout master blog in 2005 and then last February, started the podcast,
And this is the 70th weekly program of the podcast
And I am as surprised as you are that I'm able to do it every week.
It started off as an experiment and sounded like it might be kind of fun,
And I like to talk and I like the sound of my own voice, because if you don't,
it's pretty hard to put a podcast together.
How is this experiment been going?
So we'll just talk for a moment about the past, present and future.
When you're doing something like a podcast or a blog or something like that,
inevitably you need to deal with statistics, because there are only two things that indicate
whether or not you are being successful.
You hear from other people and you also need to kind of look at your statistics
and see, well you know, is this, is this mattering enough for me to put the effort into it?
Statistics naturally have a bad reputation, and a well deserved one-
And they're a really poor way to calculate success online
because there's just so many ways to spend them.
They give you one perspective, and only one thin perspective, of how effective your work is.
The actual contact from people who listen and read, by email and comments,
are a much better indicator that we've gained some measure of success with this.
The blog itself is just a little over six years old-
a long time ago past the one million page views and half million visits,
which sounds wow. that sounds incredible,
But I got to tell you honestly. most people find the blog through a Google search
and they look at a page or two and that's it.
About 900 people become readers and followers of the blog in the podcast.
At present, we've become a part of this burgeoning, growing experimental online scouting community.
About 700 people subscribe to the blog through email.
About 900 people like the Scoutmaster blog page on Facebook.
I'm trying to figure out how many people listen to the podcast
and I've kind of given up because it's very, very tricky.
You can do all the research you want out there and I got to tell you
nobody knows how this works.
I mean, podcasting has been around now for about five or six years
and there's a lot of competing theories on how to tell how many people are listening
and there's competing services that claim to be able to tell you that.
But in the end there's really no easy answer.
So I keep my eye on one basic number.
It's the feed that I use to put the podcast on iTunes
and it tells me that the 70 published podcasts-
well, 69 at this reading- but those 69 podcasts
have been downloaded about 16,000 times
Right now, on average of about 300 to 350 people listen to the podcast
according to that particular metric,
And I feel that that's reasonably successful.
Say again, when I hear back from people-
and I do get to hear from them now on a regular basis-
it was a little quiet there for the first few months,
but I do get to hear from people on a regular basis,
and that proves that this is reasonably successful
and that it is important
and that it does the service that I was hoping when we started out.
So what's the future look like for all this?
Again, really, really hard to tell
If you followed all of the podcast revolution. in its first iteration,
everybody thought it was going to be a huge game changer,
but things were just going to never be the same,
and that promise pretty much faded.
It's turned into something a lot different.
About 85% of people in the United States are online, I am told,
and about 45% of them know and understand the term podcast,
and only 23% have actually listened to a podcast.
Now, when you're talking about the United States,
23% is 70 million people.
If you, like me, sit down every once in a while
and look at technology and look at what we're able to do
and the way we're able to communicate with one another now,
and you just imagine what it was like 20, 25 years ago.
you're just astounded.
You might be listening to me off of your computer
as you sit at your desk at home.
You might be listening to this podcast from a portable device
like an iPod or an iPhone.
It may be plugged into your car as you're driving to and from work.
I know a lot of people do that.
You may be listening to it as you're walking around the neighborhood.
It's just remarkable.
If we're going to continue to build this
interesting experimental community of scout leaders online,
I'm going to look for you for more and more ideas
and more and more of what works,
so that you can participate actively in that.
Now you may be sitting on an idea or a technique
or something like that that you think is kind of insignificant,
but it works for you.
You may have come across something that you found inspiring
or uplifting.
What we're coming to now is the kind of
incumbency on all of us to participate
and to share that type of stuff,
And you can do it fairly easily because you can email me,
You can call and leave a voicemail message,
And I'll tell you how to do all that at the end of the podcast.
But wow, what a world,
What an amazing resource we have in the Internet
and in being able to use this type of social media stuff.
I'm constantly amazed by it all,
And I sure appreciate those of you who listen,
who follow the podcast and the blog
And with that in mind, let's take a look
and see what came through the mailbag in the past week.
James Chaplin is a scout master in troop 1833
in Haymarket, Virginia,
And he says this:
thank you for your discussion on unit commissioners.
That was in podcast number 69.
It came at the right time. as a scout master,
I rarely see my unit commissioner.
His commitment to me has been that I already know more
than he does on scouting, so there's no need,
But I can always use a second set of experienced eyes
with fresh ideas.
I've been considering stepping down after five years
as a scout master and trying to make a difference
as a commissioner that actually makes unit visits.
Thank you, James.
Thanks for being in touch.
I'm glad that the commissioner info was timely.
I almost didn't do that piece because I didn't know
whether it would be of interest to people
or if it would be particularly effective for the audience,
But I've gotten a lot of feedback on it
And you know. so I appreciate you being in touch, James.
David said this: as a new scout leader,
I have really appreciated the information.
Your blog has become one of my favorite reads.
Well thanks, David.
I appreciate your kind words.
Mark in San Diego said
quite a rendition of your son's and your scout career,
And he's talking about the scout dad story in podcast 69.
It sure turned on the waterworks for me
and reminded me to keep enjoying my time
as a new to be 16-year-old Eagle Scout son.
These times are indeed precious
Well, thanks, Mark.
I'm glad that the story we touched home with you,
as it did with many others.
I've gotten several different comments
and feedback about it.
I may not have made it clear that that story
was more a bit of poetic license
based on some of my experiences,
the experience of my scouting colleagues,
and was intended not to be so much a recitation
of my history as a dramatic reading,
because I find these common threads
in a lot of our experiences.
And in a moment we're going to talk about
a question I have from a scout dad
about how to work with his son
and be a scout master at the same time.
But thanks, Mark,
Thanks for being in touch.
Frank Maynard said this.
I enjoyed your reply to the anonymous
Lister who sought advice on being a district commissioner.
It's a great rundown from a unit perspective.
I want what we'd like to see in the way of commissioner service.
I'm not sure I agree with the concept
of fixed term limits for commissioners,
but a change in terminology may be in order.
Commissioner has an onerous ring to it
And, as Frank said in his email,
there's not a whole lot of chance
that that change will ever be made.
The statement I made about limiting the term
of service for commissioners has been
one of the more commented upon parts
of the last podcast.
I think that the idea of turning over
the commissioner service on a three-year rotation
is probably still a good idea
If people want to talk to me about it.
I'm not going to try and discuss it right now,
But you want to talk to me about it, be in touch.
Jamie Humphries got in touch with us.
He is from Flugerville, Texas,
where he's a cubmaster and a chaplain crew
and a unit commissioner.
That's a lot of hats, Jamie.
He says: hey, Clark, always a fantastic job. on the podcast,
I was listening to podcast number 69.
And as a unit commissioner,
I really thought the tips on commissioner service
was right on.
I felt it was more like a counselor position
than a policing activity.
Well, good for you, Jamie.
As a cubmaster
I didn't have a unit commissioner that visited.
It would have helped a lot to have a mentor and a friend.
The oath you suggested for commissioners
was right on the money
And I really loved your story about the scout dad.
Thanks for your insight.
Keep it up. It really helps.
I spread the word about the blog
and the podcast in the Austin Texas area.
Every new lead that reads it and listens
thanks me for turning them on to it.
Thank you, Jamie.
I'm glad you're enjoying the cast.
It's always good to hear from you
And I especially appreciate the comment
about commissioners being a counseling position
rather than a policing position.
That's a pretty big disconnect sometimes.
I've been droning on and on here a little bit.
You forgive me.
It's a big special podcast for me, number 70..
We're going to go ahead and complete the whole show here
with an answer to an email question-
Well, not actually an email question,
An answer to a Facebook question
about working with your son
when you're a leader in a scout troop,
And we'll do that here in just a moment.
Well, we've already gotten started,
But let's keep moving on, shall we?
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Hi, I'm Kevin Callan and I'm listening to Scoutmaster iPod.
No, I can't.
What is it called again?
Hi, I'm Kevin Callan, the happy camper,
and you're listening to the Scoutmaster podcast.
Beautiful, beautiful.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Now, if you're on Facebook, you can follow the Scoutmaster blog
in the podcast.
Get on Facebook, look for Scoutmaster blog
and like Scoutmaster blog
And then you'll see all the announcements
that come across about new posts on the blog
and new editions of the podcast.
And every once in a while somebody
will ask a question on Facebook
And then the whole group of 900-plus people
who are friends of the Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
join in.
Andre asked this question.
He said: OK, here's one for all of you out there.
I'm a new assistant scoutmaster,
So you can see the question is, from that point of view,
Understanding. it is now up to the boys,
my son included, to do it for themselves.
What approach do you use to nudge them along
when they seem to stall out on a merit badge
or any other project?
My son has four badges started but does not
seem motivated to finish them.
What can I do to motivate him without being
an interfering dad or an interfering Scoutmaster?
Andre, first of all, thanks for asking the question,
But that's a pretty big question.
A lot of people join me in trying
to offer you some advice.
I'll begin by repeating what I had to say:
You can't stop being a Scoutmaster
and you can't stop being a dad,
And every single dad at times will encounter
the same frustrations you're experiencing.
I know that I did
My best. advice is: scouting is something
our sons get to do for themselves and we get to observe.
I think it's important that you understand
it's possible that your input, however well intentioned,
can be interpreted by your son as being interfering.
Maybe you can put your dad hat on for a minute-
And when I say a minute I'm kind of being literal there-
Short period of time-
And tell him that you want to see him finish what he started
and ask him how he's going to make that happen
And if he needs any help from you,
and you may get a response there and you may not
just let him know that you're on the job.
You can also leave it alone
And he may finish them or he may not,
Because in the grand scheme of things
this may not be a big deal.
A lot of Scouts begin merit badges and don't finish them
because they find out that they're not all that interested
in the merit badge
And I really don't have a problem with that.
I'd rather they move on to something else
that really interests them.
Another thing you can do is ask another assistant scout master
or the scout master or another adult leader
within your troop to kind of follow up with your son
on that and offer to do the same for his son,
And that way you have a little plausible deniability
about your scheme, although the boys usually managed
to figure that out pretty quickly.
There's a whole thicket of issues between dads and sons
in scouting and in sports and so on,
But there are great opportunities to work things out together
and to watch them grow.
Sometimes our job is to be that dissatisfied parent
and to challenge them,
And sometimes our job is to step back and watch.
And it's really difficult to know what to do
in any given situation.
And I want to hasten to add
this is the same thing.
Being a mom is different, yes,
but the same advice applies when it comes
to the relationship you have with your son in scouting.
If you think you're gonna interfere in the situation,
trust your instincts and leave it be.
Mike Mansor joined in the conversation
and he said I followed my two boys through Cubs
and now into Boy Scouts.
I was always a den leader and now I'm their scout master.
I'm not sure who this is the hardest on- me or them.
My oldest is now our senior patrol leader.
Try that on for difficulty.
Yeah, been there, done that, Mike.
In the end I think you have to let them go
at their own pace.
That's good advice, Mike.
Sharon Miller said: definitely nudge.
I can only assume that your son is maybe 11 or 12
and mom probably still has to remind him to take a shower.
So nudging is, you know, it's very parental,
It's very proper,
It's what you do.
Randall Cox said: keep it fun.
His friends should be there.
Competition with them will be a motivator
for the first few years.
Well, that's true too.
You know, the other scouts will probably do a better job
of motivating him than you will.
And then again there are guys that just don't care
what anybody else has.
They kind of make up their own minds
and they decide they're gonna finish something or not,
And I think that is equally laudable.
But thanks, Randall, for joining in the conversation.
Farrell Gilmer said: there's not a lot you can do
for the other boys without their parents being involved
in their scouting career.
Some boys are more motivated than others
And you can mention over and over to some
that they have quite a few requirements to finish.
But besides that, if their parents aren't helping
or pushing their son, there's not a whole lot you can do
For your own son. have them set a goal for each badge.
My son set a goal to get Eagle before he turned 15..
In order to motivate him, I would find him
playing his video game and would say:
you know, you have to work on this merit badge.
He would say yes,
And I would ask him when he was going to work on it.
He generally said that he would get to it
and I would then reply: what was your goal? again,
As soon as I said that he would sigh, get up
and work on his requirements,
He got his Eagle one month before he turned 15..
Farrell- that's a good story,
I like that-
Didn't get his Eagle six months before he turned 15..
But again on the theme, sometimes that parental nudge
is the only appropriate action to have
And I like what Farrell did there.
Well, tell me what your goal was again,
Remind me what you committed yourself to,
And that's done pretty non-judgmentally
and it's done in a spirit of fairness
And I really like the balance of that particular statement.
Finally, Andre Crawford said
thanks to everyone for the comments.
So far I've been taking the hands-off approach
and only asking my son how it's going every eight
to 10 days.
I don't want to interfere
but I don't want to see him fail either.
It's a fine line. I'm learning to walk
And you know, Andre, it's a fine line
that we all go through. we all work with.
It's frustrating at times.
It is difficult to know what to do, what not to do
And, let's face it, we're gonna make mistakes as we go along.
But be patient with yourself, be patient with your son
And remember that you are having one rare experience
in today's world:
You are working right along with him,
watching and observing and seeing him grow up
in a way that a lot of parents don't get
get the chance to see.
I hope everything works out.
If you have a question for me
and the rest of the audience for the Scoutmaster podcast,
you can go ahead and get in touch
and we're gonna tell you how to do that in just a moment.
["Skoutmaster Podcasts"].
Thanks for listening, and here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom. that's scoutmastercgcom.
There you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter,
which is a monthly digest at the Scoutmaster blog
and podcast with some great scouting resources
around a monthly theme
And every newsletter includes a giveaway
from one of our affiliate sponsors.
This month the theme is backpacking
and I've got a good three step plan
to get your troop backpacking
if you're not already out there doing it.
Just some information to get you started,
some good resources that help fill in some of the blanks.
And our giveaway is from the folks at Right in the Rain.
It's a outdoor journal kit with a cool zipper pouch
and a pen and a Right in the Rain book
and a great product.
And we really appreciate the help coming
to the Scoutmaster blog and podcast
from the folks at Right in the Rain.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or a review or a rating.
And you can call this phone number,
4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-0-2, to leave a voicemail comment or question.
that will then be recorded and included in the Scoutmaster
newsletter
And that will then be recorded
and included in the Scoutmaster podcast
and included in the Scoutmaster podcast.
So that's 4-8-4-7-3-4-0-0-0-2..
Call that from any phone.
You'll hear a welcome announcement from me
And then you can go ahead and record a question,
a comment, a review, a song, a joke, whatever you like,
And that recording may be part
of the next Scoutmaster podcast.
You can follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and Scoutmaster CG on Twitter.
And finally, you can email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions at ScoutmasterCG.
or one word: ScoutmasterCG at Verizonnet,
ScoutmasterCG at Verizonnet.
I'll bet you didn't know this, but the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America.
No, no,
They are not endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, you know what?
It's really only me.
I have a microphone and a laptop computer
and a little time to put into it,
And we're trying to lend a hand
to Scoutleaders and making sure that we're
able to do the same thing.
Well, 70 weeks ago we started out with
having Sir Robert Baden Powell
welcome us at the beginning of the podcast.
That's what you hear when it says:
now to use Scoutmasters. that's a recording
of his voice,
And we end up with him at the end of the podcast.
So we're going to go ahead, and
we're going to go ahead, and
at the end of the podcast.
So, Sir Robert, it is time,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, thank you very much, sir.
Once again, thanks to all of you
who are listening and participating,
And we will talk to you again next time.